from Deep Sea sci-fi to a Hitchcock
classic if you want to see any of these
movies or TV shows you best dig out the
DVD player because you won't find them
online anytime soon despite being one of
the most successful directors in the
history of Cinema some of James
Cameron's back catalog remains
unavailable online take for example the
1994 Arnold Schwarzenegger film True
Lies which cannot be rented purchased or
streamed legally in the United States
although it is available on Disney Plus
in the UK another such filamency Abyss a
1989 sci-fi film about a group of
scientists to attempt to recover a
sunken nuclear submarine and its crew as
they explore the depths of the ocean the
team comes across a non-terrestrial
intelligence surrounding the damage
craft the abyss wasn't exactly a huge
success at the box office grossing just
over 50 million dollars domestically but
it won plenty of plaudits from critics
that since become a minor cult classic
however while it was previously
streaming on Netflix The Abyss has not
been available to watch on the internet
for an extended period of time in fact
the movie hasn't been released on
Blu-ray although Cameron himself has
hinted that a 4K remastered release is
on the way based on the Thomas M dish
story of the same name The Brave Little
Toaster is a 1987 animated film from
director Jerry Reese it follows an
anthropomorphic toaster who comes to
life when humans aren't around kind of
like a more breakfasty version of the
toys from Toy Story along with a wide
array of other electrical appliances
it's supposed to set cell to try and
find its owner after they fail to return
to the holiday home for several years
things could be worse you know
how how what how could they be worse
they couldn't I lied despite limited
success of the box office The Brave
Little Toaster was able to find some
popularity on home video and received
largely positive reviews from critics
the film was broadcast on the Disney
Channel and enjoyed a small theatrical
release and was later followed by two
sequels The Brave Little Toaster to the
rescue and The Brave Little Toaster goes
to Mars both of which are available to
stream online through Disney plus
however the original film was absent
from any streaming service and cannot be
purchased or rented online although many
modern TV fans might not know it Murphy
Brown was one of the most popular
sitcoms on television to the 1980s and
1990s it aired for nearly a decade and
broadcast a total of 260 episodes across
that time Candice Bergen portrayed
Murphy Brown a recovering alcoholic who
works as an investigative journalist as
if you need proof that Murphy Brown was
a Bonafide of Pop Culture phenomenon
take a look at the countless Awards it
won including numerous Prime Time Emmys
so why is Murphy Brown destined to
remain solely in the world of physical
media well it's complicated the one
thing the show was produced by Warner
Brothers despite hearing on CBS so it's
not actually clear where it could stream
it also utilized a large amount of Music
meaning that songs that all need to be
licensed all over again and the sheer
number of Motown hits featured in the
series makes it cost prohibitive
unfortunately you won't have much luck
finding the show on modern home media
either as only the first season was ever
released on DVD Moonlighting was a
comedy drama series that started Bruce
Willis as a private detective and Sybil
Shepard as his business partner airing
on ABC between 1985 and 1989 the series
cross genres frequently broke the fourth
wall and included a number of fantasy
elements the show was also responsible
for bringing Willis to the Public's
attention and had a hit theme song from
Jazz star Al Jarreau Moonlighting
garnered a positive reception and won a
number of high-profile Awards including
several Primetime Emmys however it has
failed to appear online in any form but
somehow let's suggesting that this may
be due to music rights issues this
series contains a large number of songs
in every episode and Licensing all of
that music might not be worth the cost
of adding it to Hulu or Disney Plus
kids today it's always gimme gimme gimme
Let It Be is a 1970 documentary film
that shows the creation of The Beatles
final studio album the film features no
narration or interviews instead showing
the musicians as they prepare for the
upcoming record by rehearsing songs and
discussing the recording process
although there are no obvious fights
depicted in the documentary the tension
between each of the band's members is
palpable Let It Be provides a
fascinating glimpse into the internal
conflicts that will cause them to split
up a month before the movie's release
the film culminates in a full recording
of the band's iconic final rooftop
concert while let it be has been given a
few limited home media releases in the
past it has not been reissued or made
available via streaming speaking to
Rolling Stone Paul McCartney refuted
rumors that he had blocked its release
but even today fans still cannot access
the original documentary however much of
the footage from the film was later used
in Peter Jackson's documentary series
The Beatles get back which is available
on Disney plus Kevin Smith's view as
skew Universe movies might not be to
everyone's taste but films like clerks
and Chasing Amy have a crew to dedicate
hated fan followings and widespread
phrase from critics the 1999 film Dogma
is in the same mode although it hasn't
enjoyed the same attention of some of
Smith's older releases featuring an
ensemble cast driven by a whole heap of
star power the story follows a group of
religious figures attempting to prevent
two fallen angels from defying God's
Will by returning to heaven and acts
that would have disastrous consequences
for reality the main issue blocking
Dogma from streaming online appears to
stem from a disagreement between Smith
and Harvey Weinstein the director told
Cinema Blend that Weinstein owns the
rights to the film and that the disgrace
producer is blocking a sale that would
give Smith control over its release the
fall is a 2006 movie by Indian director
tarsem Singh based on the Bulgarian film
yo ho ho the story follows a stun man
who befriends a young girl in the
hospital will recovering from a number
of severe injuries to help Stave off
boredom he tells His companion
Fantastical stories that come to life in
the girl's imagination starring Lee Pace
as a stuntman Roy Walker the film
received mixed reviews and didn't fare
particularly one of the box office
although Roger eberts gave it 4 out of 4
stars and recommended it as a once in a
lifetime experience produced without any
major Studio involvement the fall has
failed to materialize on any streaming
platforms and isn't available to rent or
buy meaning the only way to see it is by
tracking down one of the limited DVD or
blu-ray releases before he found
widespread Fame in Brooklyn 99 Andre
Brower was one of the stars of another
police based television series homicide
life on the street do you know what
gravitas sounds like greetings all based
on the David Simon bug that would also
Inspire the wire this NBC series ran
from 1993 until 1999 spanning Seven
Seasons 122 episodes and a TV movie this
show is highly regarded by many in 2007
time even counted it among the best
television shows ever made life on the
street was also nominated for dozens of
awards including a number of Primetime
Emmy Awards several different DVD
releases have been released over the
years but there is currently no way to
legally access it online this may well
be another music rights issue as a show
features a lot of contemporary music
although the involvement of a number of
different production companies probably
didn't help either directed by Scott
Hicks the 1996 movie shine is largely
based on the real-life events
surrounding pianist David helfgott from
a young age the future musician is
forced to learn to play at the
insistence of his abusive father but the
pressure of Performing eventually leads
him into a mental health crisis Jeffrey
Rush brought the tortured pianist to
life and shine and one considerable
Acclaim for his performance while the
film in general was almost universally
praised by critics and audiences sadly
shine is not available for streaming in
any location the movie was released on
DVD shortly after its theatrical debut
while a Blu-ray version came out in 2010
so while it's not easy to find and watch
it's not impossible either Green Street
Hooligans is a 2005 crime film that
stars Charlie Hunnam and Leo Gregory as
British football Hooligans were joined
by an American and visiting his family
the film charts are the Green Street to
lead fights over rival roofs and travels
to football matches across the country
however events quickly take a tragic
turn as Elijah Wood's character Matt is
exposed to the gruesome consequences of
hooligan culture those living outside of
the U.S might have more luck being able
to watch Green Street Hooligans it's
available to buy and rent on a variety
of services in the UK for example
including Microsoft YouTube Amazon and
apple this may well be because Green
Street Hooligans known simply as Green
Street in the UK simply lacks
International appeal as the subject
matter is very specific to that country
as such it has not been picked up by any
overseas streaming services or digital
Distributors based on the comic series
of the same name Tales from the Crypt
was an HBO Anthology series that ran for
Seven Seasons between 1989 and 1996. it
mixed elements of horror comedy and Dark
Fantasy to deliver stories that often
included graphic violence and mature
themes the series was hosted by a
mysterious figure known as the Crypt
Keeper who would introduce storylines
and talk directly to the viewer over the
years a number of guest stars featured
in Tales from the Crypt and the series
also received a number of spin-offs
what's the matter with you you want to
keep that 90 pound corpse for the rest
of your death camping
it shows absence from Modern streaming
services including HBO Max appears to be
due to complicated rights issues TNT
executive Kevin Reilly even told
deadline that Tales from the Crypt
suffers from the most complicated right
structure he has ever seen in his career
the fact that the comic book series has
been sold multiple times to different
owners has undoubtedly made it even
harder to reboot or re-release a
franchise in recent times created by
John Beckerman and Rob Burnett with the
help of David Letterman Ed is a comedy
drama series of first hit television
screens in 2000 the show follows Tom
cavanagh's character Ed Stevens a down
on his luck lawyer who loses his job
after making an expensive mistake to
make matters worse he discovers that his
wife is having an affair and immediately
decides to go back to his hometown where
he chases the affections of a local
woman and reunites with his best friend
having a run for Four Seasons and
received a generally positive reviews
you'd probably expect Ed to be available
on a variety of platforms but it isn't
even the show's creators are unsure why
it hasn't been added to any digital
service with Burnett suggesting that it
might be due to a combination of Music
rights and the fact that NBC Universal
and Paramount co-owned the series The
1940 Alfred Hitchcock movie Rebecca is a
film adaptation of Daphne de maurier's
1938 novel of the same name Rebecca
Stars Lawrence Olivier as a widower Who
falls in love with a young woman played
by Joan Fontaine like many of
Hitchcock's other films though this is
not so much a simple romance as it is a
psychological Thriller one that revolves
around the dark secret in the Widow was
passed the movie was a huge success when
it was released and went to Academy
Awards including best picture even with
its Awards success in a claim Rebecca
cannot be watched in any digital format
it occasionally airs on Turner Classic
Movies and the Criterion Collection has
released a film on both DVD and Blu-ray
the fact that it is not available
digitally has never been explained and
they're so doubly confusing considering
that many other celebrated Alfred
Hitchcock films are readily accessible
online
thank you